hey youtubers is Charlie Deadpool kills
the x-men Deadpool is dropping this week
Ryan Reynolds explains a little bit
about how it fits in the continuity some
of the Easter eggs that you can look
forward to in the movie so here's a
quick breakdown when you go see the
movie this week they're supposed to be
over 800 Easter eggs like a lot way more
than you would expect in a normal movie
some will be in jokes that they make
some will be visual references some will
be very literal Easter eggs like
post-credit scenes stuff like that
they'll be all over the place there's
many different ways to include Easter
eggs in a movie one of the best ones to
look forward to is how Deadpool fits
into the x-men continuity Ryan Reynolds
said that they make fun of the timeline
because of all the rebooting that
happened with Days of Future past it is
an x-men universe movie but the way
Deadpool fits into the x-men movies is
kind of the way Deadpool fits into x-men
comics it's kind of its own thing but
there is a lot of crossover there's a
lot of referencing going on so it's a
little bit weird it's not like an
Avengers movie where you literally see
all the actors on screen talking about
things that happen in each other's
movies you're more likely to see
Deadpool doing things that he does in
the comics making fun of people for
things they did in the past whitby turns
of phrase making fun of Wolverine
Origins in the movie and there is a
whole lot of that so it's gonna be
awesome
in terms of timeline you can see all the
cars in the movie look way newer than
what's going on in the 80s during x-men
apocalypse
so obviously this movies happening after
that we see colossus negasonic teenage
warhead in the x-mansion so obviously
there's a lot of x-men stuff going on
but don't expect to see James McAvoy or
a lot of the other big x-men characters
if you saw the Deadpool vs. Wolverine
video I posted before the Superbowl
Bryan Reynolds has been saying he wants
to play dead bull for forever he said
probably the most literal x-men
crossover that he's gonna appear in next
would be an x-force movie Fox is
developing an x-force movie but it kind
of got put on the back burner before
x-men apocalypse went into development I
think they wanted to fast-track the
Bryan Singer films because they know
those are gonna make a ton of money so
x-force is still happening and there's
also a new mutants movie which is a
completely separate thing they're
developing that too but because they
need to get people who don't understand
x-men to go see these movies I think
that they would push x-force before New
Mutants just because it has X in the
title so you can sell it as an x-men
film even though it's technically
whole different team and you probably up
whole different characters Wolverines
psylocke Deadpool all been part of
x-force in the comics x-force number one
the comic book is the second
best-selling comic of all time I think
it's all like four or five million
copies but that was right after they
introduced Deadpool in the comics in the
90s so Deadpool became this really
awesome character destroyed cable and
his team in the New Mutants so when
x-force debuted everyone went crazy and
they actually they rolled Deadpool into
that comic a lot faster than they
attended to originally originally
Deadpool was just kind of floating
around like oh this is cool character
but cable was really the main attraction
but when Deadpool blew up they're like
okay let's let's get him in there faster
so Deadpool in X force for a long long
time
so regardless of what the x-force movie
does I would expect to see cable and
Deadpool appear in that cable would
probably be the main character in that
film if Deadpool wasn't but they
probably do the x-men apocalypse x-men
Days of Future past thing where even
though you have tons of big x-men
characters huge actors really Wolverine
is the main character of that film
Days of Future past is unofficially a
Wolverine film even though it's an
ensemble film it's really a Wolverine
film so x-force is probably gonna do the
same thing where you have cable and
Deadpool Deadpool blowing up gonna make
a ton of money so of course he's gonna
be really big and whatever film he shows
up in there is no date on that x-force
film but I think depending on how
Deadpool does and what they want to do
for the Deadpool sequel they might
fast-track it
now I should say x-force and the
Deadpool sequel will privy to different
films like don't want the Deadpool
franchise to be its own thing you know
it's a solid performer people will
totally roll out for it x-force can be
its own thing too so if it doesn't do
well they don't have to do another one
but if it does do well they can turn it
into its own franchise everybody wants
their own franchise like when you look
at the Avengers films the Avengers is a
franchise by itself but each of the
characters has their own franchise -
Captain America is his own franchise I
would argue that the Captain America
franchise is actually better than the
Avengers franchise even though the
Avengers is really awesome idea but the
other really cool thing that I wanted to
tease about the Deadpool movie is that
there is a naked fight scene make all
the swinging swords crossing swords
jokes that you want to but it's he and
Ajax I'm assuming this naked fight
happens sometime when he blows up the
Weapon X program or what
whoever it is they're calling the Weapon
X program in this movie technically dr.
Kiehl bruised lab in the comics is an
offshoot from Weapon X it even shadier
version of Weapon X if that's even
possible so just looking at the x-men
apocalypse Super Bowl trailer they
posted this weekend with Psylocke going
crazy with her SCI blade do you want to
see Psylocke in Deadpool in the x-force
movie with cable and do you want that to
be its own thing or do you want that to
be the Deadpool sequel I'm gonna go
ahead and assume that most of you want a
Deadpool sequel and x-force more is
always better but if Ryan Reynolds is
gonna be Deadpool for forever
I think he's gonna be old man Deadpool
in ten years and they want to reboot the
x-men franchise I want to see Deadpool
kills the x-men I feel like that would
be a good third Deadpool movie you don't
want to do it right away because they
just rebooted the x-men universe and
they're spinning out these new
characters they might do a Dark Phoenix
saga but Deadpool kills the x-men would
be a perfect movie somewhere in the
middle of that new Dark Phoenix trilogy
and when I say Dark Phoenix trilogy I
have no idea how many Dark Phoenix
movies that are gonna do I'm just saying
that they could spin it out into new
trilogy Hollywood is very comfortable
with the idea of trilogies the newest
thing in the last like five or six years
is they turned the third movie into two
movies so you get four movies out of
three it's a total money grab but it
allows you to do a bigger final movie so
whatever but let me know do you want
them to actually do Deadpool kills the
x-men at a certain point obviously he
wouldn't kill all the x-men just the
ones that do not renew their contracts
think of Avengers Infinity Ward doing
the same thing with the Marvel
characters actors are reaching the end
of their contracts so naturally you have
this big war and you kill off the ones
that don't want to keep doing Marvel
movies then you replace them with new
characters like Captain Marvel Black
Panther all the new characters they just
introduced you get the idea but tonight
crazy is happening on the flash so
you're say I already feel like it's
gonna be my favorite two-part episode
this year be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll be doing a reverse flash
ring giveaway and there will be more
Marvel movie videos this week so while
you guys wait for all that stuff to post
you can click here for all my Super Bowl
trailer videos and you can click here
for all my Deadpool videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you